a tech company this is real just
launched a new service called invisible
girlfriend yes this is I'm not making
this up for guys who are having trouble
dating that are lonely the company
customizes a fake girlfriend that will
call text and email you for $24.99 a
month $24.99 a month you'll get text
emails phone yeah the Creator says the
service is gonna feel very real I think
maybe a little too real check out their
ad invisible girlfriend offers lots of
exciting add-ons so you're invisible
relationship grows just like a real
relationship after six months your
invisible girlfriend demands you become
Facebook official at an extra five
dollars a month after one year it moves
in with you for an additional $30 a
month after two years an invisible
condom breaks at five hundred dollars
which leads to an invisible shotgun
wedding at just ten thousand dollars two
invisible kids and an invisible terrier
mix for just twelve hundred dollars a
month after nine years invisible
alienation of affection at a rate of 17
dollars a month plus liver damage
an invisible mistress at no additional
cost to you
and finally invisible alimony for 50% of
your assets invisible girlfriend fake
love real sad
[Applause]
you